The Joe Rogan Experience my uncle John
Kennedy
you know did that he he refused to go to
war so he he was surrounded by military
industrial complex and
um and he learned very early and an
intelligence apparatus that he realized
early on that the purpose of the CIA and
the intelligence apparatus
was to create a constant pipeline of new
Wars for them for the military
industrial complex the day three days
before he took the oath of office
Eisenhower who is the outgoing president
gave what is probably the most important
speech in American history which was you
know where he warned against the
military industrial complex I was at my
uncle's inauguration I was in Washington
that day
it was a you know a six-year-old boy
and I was sitting on the stands behind a
minute during in front of him during his
inauguration
and he understood that and two months
later the military and intelligence came
to him and said we got it uh we got it
invade Cuba and he was like I'm not
going into Cuba and I'm not going to let
the military and they said well we got
all these Cubans trained and they're
going to go attack Astro
and he said well we can't the U.S
government can't be doing that we can't
be attacking we I don't like what Castro
is doing down there but it's not the
United States jobs that dictate what
kind of governments other countries have
and they said uh well as soon as they
land there's going to be a big
revolution everybody's going to rise up
and they're going to overthrow Castro
and he said well you can't use the U.S
military and they ended up bringing
those guys over with
uh United Fruit boats and and in the
middle of it the night they came to him
and said they're getting wiped out on
the beach and you need to send in the
military and invade and he said
we're not going to do it and he he
stopped out of that meeting
and he realized they had been lying to
him and trying to trick him and he said
I want to take the CIA and shatter it
into a thousand pieces and Scatter it to
the winds and um and then
you know for the next a thousand days of
his presidency he was at War
with his military and and intelligence
apparatus they tried to get him to go
into Laos he said no they tried to get
him to go into Vietnam with the combat
troops they said that we need 250 000
combat troops
he refused everybody around him want him
to go into Vietnam he sent 16 000
military advisers
has fewer people than he said to get
James Meredith into Ole Miss in Jackson
Mississippi to get one black man into
school he sent few words in Vietnam they
weren't allowed to fight that many of
them did they vote Riley The Rules of
Engagement
in October of 1963 he heard
at some of his Green Berets have been
killed over there and he said I want a
total casualty list from Vietnam
and his aide came to him and said 75
Americans have died
he said that's too many and he signed
that Day a national security ordering
all troops out of Vietnam U.S troops
the first thousand over the next month
and then the rest by the beginning of
1965.
and um and then a month later he was
killed
so
um but his view was is that he believed
that the view of American abroad should
not be you know a soldier with a gun it
should be a Peace Corps volunteer
building you know Wells and it should be
usaid helping poor people and it should
be Alliance for Progress building middle
class
and that's what he did and he just
started the Kennedy milk program to to
you know give him nutrition to poor kids
all over the world as a result of that
in Africa today there are more statues
to John Kennedy more boulevards named
after more hospitals schools
universities Avenues and all the major
cities named after him than any other
president
and that is the the the the the Chinese
have taken that template
and done the same thing now and they are
you know all these countries that were
supposedly allied with us
are now realign with the Chinese and
they're switching to their currency
because the Chinese are not there to
kill people they're there you know to
build roads to build universities to
build colleges
and it turns out that people like that a
lot more and you know we should be
projecting economic power around the
globe and not military power it will
make us much stronger but what do you
think happens when you get into office
like if you're you're talking about your
uncle who's assassinated and you believe
the intelligence agencies were part of
that what happens to you
well I gotta be careful
I mean I'm aware of that and I'm not you
know I
I'm aware of the of that danger and you
know I don't live in fear of it
um you know at all but I'm not stupid
about it and I take precautions